this is one thing i got wrong in my book
which is i said that
most leaders will uh either
experience an existential flex once
maybe twice sometimes never in a career
i never expected that every leader would
be facing it simultaneously but the
principles are still
are still the same whether we're all
going through it together or not
which is it's not about the daily
flexibility of business this is profound
180 degree strategic shift
[Music]
i'll give you my favorite example um in
the late 1970s
uh apple's already a successful company
they've already come up the success of
the apple one the apple ii steve jobs is
already a famous ceo
and understand uh apple had a just cause
they had a
vision a very clear vision which is they
wanted to empower individuals to stand
up to incumbent
uh uh power they wanted to empower
individuals to stand up to big brother
this revolutionary spirit
and if you remember um uh that's what
they that's what they stood for right
the computer revolution they were one of
the leaders of the computer revolution
um uh and jobs and a few of his senior
executives
um as executives do went and visited
another company and they got a tour of
xerox
xerox park which is xerox's r d division
and xerox showed them something they
invented
called the graphic user interface
which allowed a computer user to click
a mouse and move a cursor across a
desktop
to use icons uh to work the computer
now this is a profound technology
because prior to that you had to learn a
computer language
so driven by the the idea that one day
an individual be able to compete against
a corporation
job jobs sees this new technology
and goes back to his team and says we
have to invest in this graphic user
interface thing he sees it as a leapfrog
technology
to advance their vision
and one of the leaders who was there
that day said we can't
we've already invested millions of
dollars and countless man-hours in a
completely different strategic direction
if we go down that path
we will blow up our own company to which
jobs
actually said better we should blow it
up than someone else
well that decision led to the macintosh
a computer user operating system
so profound that the entire software of
windows is designed to act like a
macintosh
and the reason a computer is now
household appliance
was because of their willingness to make
that profound strategic shift
and so the reason uh leaders usually
don't make
an existential flex is because they're
too afraid of the short-term losses
they're too afraid of of the disruption
even if they sometimes see it as
necessary
um one of my favorite examples of a
failure
uh was blockbuster blockbuster was the
only significant
uh national video rental chain uh you
know they were the 800 pound gorilla
and this little company called netflix
showed up
and saw the rise of the internet and the
potential for streaming in the future
the technology wasn't quite there yet
but everybody knew it was coming
but they started experimenting with an
entirely new business model called
subscription
and if you remember you could get the
dvds and keep them for as long as you
wanted
and then send them back and the ceo of
blockbuster at the time went to the
board and said i think we really need to
experiment with subscription
and the board would not allow him
because the company made twelve percent
of their revenues
from late fees they were so afraid to
give up twelve percent of revenues
that they literally committed an act of
suicide blockbuster doesn't exist and
netflix is determining the future of
television and movies now
the the the they will say the internet
put them out of business nonsense they
put themselves out of business
and so we're seeing that right now in
cobit as well
there are companies that are desperately
clinging to their old business models
but this this marketplace you know if
you're not willing to pivot
the marketplace will put you out of
business and so we're seeing
wonderful uh uh disruption happening
positive disruption taking advantage of
covid to make changes they see it highly
necessary
where they may not have made these
changes prior because they were just too
[Music]
afraid